[Music]
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new
ghostwriter footage is dropping in two
weeks episode one in two weeks
so let's break it down so what that is
is it seems like it's like a studio
promo done in found-footage form but
they're calling it a found footage
teaser but Marvel released it on their
official channel so it's like something
that they made or something that they're
gonna use inside the episode like you
figure that YouTube exists in the world
of Marvel DC all these other comic-book
universes that try to be true to life
like in civil war footage of spider-man
exists on YouTube you see like Peter
looking at it they even put some of that
in the Comic Con trailer for spider-man
homecoming there's like a classroom
scene where the teacher calls on Peter
but he's like busy on his phone watching
footage of himself on YouTube doing
spider-man things but maybe that's
what's happening here like there's some
random bystander that catches Ghost
Rider doing something his ghost writers
like oh my god that's the guy you know
like he says in the teaser oh my god
that's him is he peels away in the
charger and I know a lot of people are
like how come he's not on the motorcycle
you have to remember this isn't the
Johnny Blaze Ghost Rider he's based on
the more recent version of Ghost Rider
which is Robby Reyes who's a mechanic
that works on cars so naturally it makes
sense that his vehicle would be a car in
the first episode I think is titled the
ghost
so it'll introduce his character you'll
see how he works on screen I don't know
if they're going to give him his
abilities in the first episode or if
we'll pick up running and he'll already
be Ghost Rider
but the showrunner said they went with
him just because there's a little less
baggage like people know less about this
version of Ghost Rider so they don't
have to deal with as much of like the
extra baggage that you do when you do
very specific comic book characters like
if they did Hulk on the TV show they
would have to be very true to what's
going on in the movies what he was in
the comics when they do lesser
characters or they do relatively
brand-new characters it's not quite as
big a deal but in the tradition of most
Ghost Rider characters there are good
people that fall on hard times make a
deal that goes sideways with either the
devil or someone really bad that's the
same situation here like they always get
tricked into a deal to give them these
abilities but the devil or whoever it is
that they make that bargain with never
makes the bargain without knowing that
they're going to come out on
like you're not gonna win a bet with the
devil he would never enter into a
contract where he didn't know coming out
that he would get everything so right
off the bat he's the selling point
Ghost Rider season of agents of shield I
assume he's gonna be around for the
entire season like the first half and
the back half of the season but Inhumans
are still a big deal because there's no
really big Marvel movie on earth this
year like I mean they have dr. strange
but I'm not expecting too much crossover
with that movie in the spring movie next
year during the back half of agents of
shield is going to be guardians of the
galaxy so there's no way they're gonna
crossover with that maybe some Crees
stuff but I don't think it's gonna be
guardians related but the other really
big thing just to remind you guys shield
is now a 10:00 p.m. show which is
actually a good thing it means they can
be more graphic they don't have to worry
as much about being hardcore I mean
they're still on ABC so there's still
broadcast standards but they can have a
little bit more fun with the stories
that they tell just in general it seems
like what they're doing with this show
is giving it more parity with the
Netflix Marvel series we you know which
are really dark and gritty but amazing
so I think by moving it to 10:00 p.m.
there'll be less network involvement
which is largely I think been the source
of most of the issues agents of shield
has had because the people that write
the show the show runners the other
writers are good people they can make
good stuff usually where you fall down
is where the network planes off all the
interesting stuff from a show just to
make it more quote-unquote likeable for
the audience that they already have on
their network and I think by putting
this at NPM that'll be less of an issue
so all really good things I think you
guys will like the show a lot more now
that it's on later at night it's amazing
how much of a difference just bumping it
by two hours can make and it's not as
much of a conflict which shows on other
networks like the flash which is still
at 8 p.m. so there's no worry about
competing time slots but what's probably
gonna happen is is my flash videos will
post Tuesday night just because that'll
be the first thing to drop during the
night and then the next morning I'll
post agents of shield so be sure to
subscribe to get all that stuff there's
still a Civil War blu-ray that's going
on right now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video that'll keep going till the
blu-ray actually drops there's a big
convention this weekend so DC people
Marvel people are talking all about new
season so there'll be all kinds of new
DC Marvel stuff based on that so that'll
start posting to
why you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to learn all about
Captain America in spider-man homecoming
and you can click here to learn about
how Doctor Strange in the time gem work
into Avengers infinity war thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight